Android 5.0 runs across
our favorite screens,
from phones to tablets,
wearables, TVs, and even cars.
I'm Ankur Kotwal, a
developer advocate at Google.
And I'm going to show
you the developer
highlights of this
tasty new treat.
Let's start with
material design.
Material design
is a new approach
for designing apps in
today's multi-device world
that takes a comprehensive
strategy to visual, motion,
and interaction design.
Android 5.0 brings
material design
to their platform with
a full set of tools
for implementing
it in your apps.
The system is
incredibly flexible,
allowing your app to express
its individual character
and brand with bold colors
and a variety of responsive UI
patterns and
theme-able elements.
The support library
has also been
updated to provide
backward-compatible UI widgets,
allowing you to bring the
modern beauty of material design
to all their devices.
Next, the lock screen lets
you surface content, updates,
and actions to users at
a glance without needing
them to unlock their device.
The notification APIs
provide visibility controls
to let you declare the
sensitivity of the information
displayed on your notifications.
This is particularly
important, as users
can choose to show or hide
sensitive content on their lock
screen.
Instant messaging apps should
declare their notification
content to be private,
whilst media playback
apps should declare
this to be public.
Heads-up notifications
display content and actions
in a small floating window
managed by the system,
no matter which app
is in the foreground.
Notifications are
appropriately themed,
and you can express
your brand further
through accent colors
and other customizations.
These enable your apps to
prominently notify users
without pulling them out
of their current activity.
You can get further details
about the new notification
APIs at the following DevByte.
WebView has been
updated to Chromium M37,
bringing security enhancements,
stability enhancements, and bug
fixes.
With this release, WebRTC,
WebAudio, and WebGL
are included.
But here's some
awesome news-- WebView
is now unbundled from
the system and can
be updated through Google Play.
This will provide the latest
web enhancements to users
and the latest Web
APIs to developers.
How cool is that?
Another cool initiative
is Project Volta,
which focuses on
improving battery life
and has resulted in
power optimizations
across the platform.
These are new tools to help
your app run efficiently
and conserve power.
Battery Historian, a
tool included in the SDK,
lets you visualize
power events over time
and understand how your
app is using power.
The JobScheduler API lets
you minimize battery impact
by setting the conditions under
which your background tasks
and others jobs should run,
such as when the device is idle,
connected to an un-metered
network, or to a charger.
The JobScheduler is one
of my favorite new APIs.
Android 5.0 ships with
the Android Runtime
known as ART as
the system default.
ART offers ahead-of-time
compilation, more efficient
garbage collection, and improved
development and debugging
features.
In many cases, it improves
the performance of your app
without you having
to change your code.
64-bit support has also come
to Android in this release.
It adds 64-bit ABIs, provides
additional address space,
and improved performance
with certain types
of compute workloads.
Apps written in Java
running on DEX bytecode
can benefit on
64-bit architectures
with no code changes.
For apps and games
that use native code,
NDK release 10b
includes 64-bit support
and is available for download.
Another new feature is
concurrent documents
in Recents, which lets you
organize your app into tasks
and present these concurrently
as individual documents
on the Recent screen.
For example, each
Chrome tab can now
be a separate
document in Recents.
Users can flip through Recents
to find the specific Chrome
tab they want and jump straight
to that site with a single tap.
A new set of capabilities is
Android in the Workplace, which
enables a unified
interaction model
across both personal
and workplace apps,
making it easier for
employees to have
a single device for
personal and workplace use.
Framework enhancements
offer a unified view
of Apps, Notifications,
and Recents
in a single launcher across both
personal and workplace apps.
For photo lovers,
the Camera2 API
gives you new APIs for managing
image capture and processing.
On supported devices, your app
can capture uncompressed YUV
captures in full eight
megapixel resolution
at 30 frames per second.
The API lets you capture a
raw sense of data and control
parameters, such as exposure
time, ISO sensitivity,
and frame duration
on a per-frame basis.
You can get further details
about using this API
at the following DevByte.
There are a boatload of new
features for game developers,
starting with support
for OpenGL ES 3.1.
This gives you compute
shaders, stencil textures,
and texture gather
for your games.
Android Extension
Pack is a new set
of extensions to
OpenGL ES that bring
desktop-class
graphics to Android.
Games will be able to take
advantage of tessellation
and geometry shaders,
and use ASTC texture
compression across
multiple GPU technologies.
The sound architecture
has been enhanced,
resulting in lower input
latency and the addition
of multichannel mixing.
This DevByte covers
enhancements for game developers
in more detail.
Android 5.0 has new
connectivity features.
Devices can now function in
Bluetooth Low-Energy Peripheral
Mode, or BLE Peripheral mode.
Apps can use this feature
to broadcast their presence
to nearby devices.
For example, you
can now build apps
that let a device function as
a pedometer or health monitor,
and transmit data to
another BLE device.
Apps can also work
with the system
to dynamically scan
for available networks
with specific capabilities,
and then automatically connect.
This is useful for when you want
to manage hand-offs to connect
to a specialized network, such
as a carrier-billing network.
There are many more
APIs in Android 5.0--
over 5,000 of them, in fact.
You can get started developing
and testing on Android 5.0
right away by downloading the
Android 5.0 platform and latest
support library from
the SDK Manager.
I look forward to seeing your
beautiful material design
apps on screens everywhere.